le gouvernement accélère l'alluré pour
limiter le trou de la sécu au centre des
préoccupations le fameux toujours aux
yeux noirs la situation est
catastrophique le trou de la sécu ne
cesse de se creuser en voilà un trou
dont il est bien difficile de se
dépêtrer des décennies qu'on nous en
parle
alors ça méritait bien une petite
explication je fait de tour de petit
courant quand des petits trous le trou
de la sécu autrement dit la dette
sociale
c'est l'ensemble des déficits cumulés
par la sécurité sociale depuis sa
création soit depuis 70 ans
une blague ou quoi non non c'est pas
vrai et des déficits il y en a eu
regardez entre 1998 et 2010 est par
exemple seuls trois années ont affiché
un excédent et en 2017
le trou de la sécurité sociale s'élevait
encore à 5,1 milliards d'euros
et pourtant plusieurs ministres ont
tenté de leur boucher ce trou de la sécu
tous la pelle à la main armée d'une
bonne dose d'optimisme
florilège mais j'ai très bon espoir sur
les bases que j'ai dit que nous pas bien
pour notre objectif ben manifestement
c'est raté
c'est à nous désormais il appartiendra
la sécurité sociale de la route dans
laquelle elle risque de s'enfoncer raté
notre politique consiste précisément à
inverser cette évolution qui n'a que
trop duré sera-t-elle on peut dire que
le trou de la sécu parce que c'est comme
cela que parle le français
le trou de la sécu il est derrière nous
raté aussi pour marisol touraine pas si
facile donc de leur boucher ce trou de
la sécu le gouvernement d'edouard
philippe et pourtant de nouvelles
promesses en 2019 tout cela ne sera que
de l'histoire ancienne
affaire à suivre
[Musique]